all right guys bang bang Darius Dale is
back yes he's not dead he's right here
Darius super excited to talk to you
let's first jump right into the Federal
Reserve they say that they are committed
to getting inflation down the inflation
number is coming down on year over year
but is it base effect or is it simply
that they have hiked interest rates high
enough and the rate is going to come
down and continue to fall
with a question man you are the best and
uh thanks again for having me back it's
always great to be here uh so I'll start
with respect to uh inflation so yes base
effects are kicking in to the year over
statistics that's been the case since uh
since July of this year what happened
specifically with the October CPI report
was pretty wonky um you know we don't
need to get into too many details
because I think I'm going to put people
to sleep if they're really outset of
this discussion but what in terms of how
the the BLS which the agency that
measures inflation calculates Medical
Care CPI a portion of that a very small
portion of the overall basket uh resets
every year based on the profits that
insurance companies make from us you
know in terms of the spread that they
pay doctors relative to our consumption
of care uh relative to what we're paying
them so that spread is effectively what
the BLS measures as the change in that
spread is what they measure as inflation
and so we had a big wholesale revision
lower in the month of October that will
impact the data over the next 12 months
now the issue with that is that because
that happened at such a important time
in asset markets where effectively
investors are you know leaning that
short very much looking for
opportunities to sort of you know chase
this Market chase this narrative into
into Santa Claus rally that caused some
very aggressive action at least in the
equity and bond markets but the reality
is when we look at the math in terms of
our data we don't see that as a very
sustainable outcome in fact we may see
various measures of core inflation and
underlying inflation if you look at
things like median CPI to mean CPI and
sticky CPI those things are actually
likely to retrace higher on a sequential
basis uh here in the month of November
as that happens do we get a pivot are
they going to Pivot when are they going
to Pivot what does that pivot look like
talk to me about the pivot that everyone
seems to be holding uh holding onto
their seats and they're like oh it's
just right around the corner when do you
think it's going to happen and what
exactly would that look like when they
do decide to maybe return to a looser
monetary policy yeah 100 so uh so looser
monetary policies uh we'll table that
for a second so I would almost argue
there's two pivots right to the markets
need to get it uh to get out to get
their hands around uh the first pivot is
the ratcheting down in the terms of the
speed of further interest rate hikes
we've already seen that priced into fed
phones Futures if you look at uh what's
implied for the December 14th meeting uh
there's over 80 percent chance
probability that they're going to hike
50 basis points which is a deceleration
from the hikes of the rate of hikes that
they've put on uh over the last three or
four meetings of the 75 basis point clip
so the first pivot mission accomplished
at least for now we think we're not so
sure that that they're going to be able
to keep that
um based on the data we're going to get
on the first core PC they prefer
deflation measure we'll get that on
December 1st December 13th we'll get the
November CPI data that I just alluded to
uh right a day before the fomc meeting
in their blackout period so it's going
to be a pretty interesting to Mark a
response to that data that's pending the
pivot you're referring to is the actual
pivot where they bring out the Bazooka
the ambulance sirens come to clean the
blood up off the streets
um it's our view
um that that pivot is is quite a ways
away it could be over a year away from
where we're sitting today and part of
the reason we say that is because we
think at least here 42 macro some of the
work we've done on the resiliency in the
US economy particularly with respect to
the consumer which is really kind of the
bolus of the content into lagging
indicators bucket that data suggests
we're probably not going to go into
recession until late 2023 maybe even as
as late as early 2024. so what happens
between now or at the end of 2022 uh
before the recession are we in the
pre-recession is is there like uh like
uh we're kind of just floating along and
then eventually like the bottom falls
out and now we're in recession like how
does that work especially if it's a year
away like that's a pretty long time
period And I think a lot of people are
already saying like no Moss like I
already feel the pain now what do you
mean I gotta wait a whole another year
until we're actually in the recession
yeah no that's that's exactly the point
um you know kind of feels like you're
dead man walking so you can look at this
two ways right you know like you know
you could say that you're on your way to
recession on day one of the new business
cycle right the day one of the new new
expansion which I guess was effectively
April 1st of 2020 after we sort of came
out of lockdown or at least the first
date started to come out of lockdown
um the reality is the recession process
really takes you know 10th takes several
quarters particularly when you don't
have the sort of Leverage cycle Dynamics
in the private sector that would suggest
more sort of material uh uh kind of
ratcheting down of activity consumption
Etc um you know if you think about like
one thing we like to look at at 42 macro
as it relates to timing the business
cycle is the spread between the 10-year
nominal treasury yield minus the 10 year
the three month nominal treasury yield
that has been uh at least you know
empirically proven to be the best
recession indicator uh and when you sort
of back test that recession indicator in
terms of when it goes uh to inversion
I.E the 10-year yield is below the three
month yield which is deeply inverted as
of today and inverted a couple of weeks
ago you know on the zero to six month
four basis you're talking about 100
chance of the economy is still growing
in terms of that particular interval uh
at least this is data going only back
the last eight business Cycles uh since
the mid-1960s
um you look at the six to 12 month Ford
interval there's a 75 chance that the
economy is still growing in the six to
12 month interval that's April of next
year through October of next year so the
75 chance the economy is likely to still
be growing when you get into this 12 to
18 month level that would be October of
23 through April 2024 that's where you
start to see uh the the math and the
percent positive the percent negative
ratio math uh flip in a way that
suggests the economy is more likely to
be in recession in that interval it's
right around kind of you know two-thirds
probability of being in recession so um
from a base case scenario standpoint
that's our modal outcome that's our base
expectation and then when you from a
Bayesian standpoint we started at later
on different things I sent you a few
charts uh one chart I'd like to for you
to pull up is slide 32 from our most
recent November macro Scotty report
presentation we put out this
presentation household sector balance
sheet is in excellent shape man Hercules
Hercules Hercules so let me let me run
you let me let me walk you through each
of these four indicators because I think
these are so four of the most important
indicators that me you know doing this
for a really long time these are for the
most important indicators at this
particular juncture of the business
cycle so so let's start with the first
uh first panel the first panel just
shows the amount of cash that's on
household balance sheets it's right
around 7.6 trillion dollars currently as
you can see it's it's well north of the
pre-cover trend it's like in Wally World
relative to anything we've ever seen uh
obviously it's on a nominal basis but
the growth rate that we've seen in this
uh in this postcode era has really been
you know obviously betrays by very
aggressive fiscal policy you had uh
stemi's you had a forgivable PPP loans
if forgivable SBA Loans I mean it was
you know you name it everyone got money
forgivable debt student loans all this
uh excess cash has really contributed to
households um you know really growing
their balance of checkable deposits and
money market funds these are these are
cash balances that at any moment can be
transformed into economic activity this
is not Time Savings that you had to wait
a year or two to get your money back
this is right now I can spend that
that's 7.6 trillion dollars that's
almost a third in GDP uh when you look
at that number on a ratio looking at the
second on this chart when you look at
that number on a ratio to to overall
household assets it's at five percent we
haven't seen that high of a ratio since
going back to the 1950s and so you know
you have to think about okay councils
feel good about their liquidity
situation you know they're not they're
the sort of reaction function to
negative news or even people getting
losing their jobs Etc
is not the same and those households
aren't going to be like well I got to
ratchet down and spend less and you know
that cascading you know kind of
reflexive uh you know Doom Loop if you
will really that really you know Trends
to trigger recession that that the the
probability of that you know really
occurring over the very near term is
actually quite low and then so that
takes me to the last two panels which we
look at it from the debt side of the
equation so that's on the household and
on the asset side equation the first two
uh panels and from a liquidity
standpoint when you look at the debt
side I think it's just as important so
the third panel here just shows a sort
of total household debt mortgages auto
loans Consumer loans Etc uh as a ratio
to nominal disposable personal income so
this is how much income you're
generating minus the taxes that you pay
to the government that ratio is
currently at at one you know currently
so we have one dollar debt per one
dollar of nominal uh disposable personal
income now you look at the last cycle
you know we were at a 134 cents on the
dollar in terms of debt to disposable
personal income that's a much higher
ratio and so it kind of tells you that
you know we have not really gotten to
levels that would be particularly
threatening more importantly we've not
really grown you know we've seen you
know I've studied you know Cycles many
cycles through various lenses and the
number one thing that I've learned about
the business cycle in terms of what
truncates it and what causes it to end
is two things you need to have two
things that happen simultaneously you
need a sharp growth rate and credit in
terms of Leverage like a metric like
this total debt to normal disposable
personal income and you also have to
have a sharp growth rate uh in debt in
The Debt Service ratio which is the
fourth panel the final panel in this
chart with a Debt Service ratio is is
the total amount of income uh this is
for the household sector and
specifically it's the total amount of
income that that the particular sector
the household sector is using to to pay
down debt either through amortization
which is paying back principal and uh
and and paying down interest so um as
you can see at 9.6 percent you know
we're at historic lows I mean we're you
know we were slightly lower in the early
phases of covet when win you know that
government was handing out trillions of
dollars but the reality is if you take
that out of the time series we are at
historic lows in terms of uh The Debt
Service ratio for the household sector
so you add all this up let me just
summarize households have a ton of cash
they probably feel really good about
that cash because it's such a high
percentage of their assets they're
actually quite unlevered and more
importantly the speed of the change in
their Leverage is not signaling anything
that's particularly onerous with respect
to the business cycle and oh by the way
the change in their Debt Service the
both the level and the change in The
Debt Service ratio was seen to suggest
that we have several quarters if not
potentially years before households have
to really start to rein in and tighten
their uh tighten their belts you know
kind of sit on their wallets if you will
so is it fair to
think about this as there were such good
times that the household balance sheets
got so strong that now that we're going
into a recession
consumers never been better prepared for
a recession yeah and this is ironically
what may push out and delay the
recessionary process because they got to
run out of cash yeah well it's not that
they have to run out of cash enough of
them have to be fired so that they start
demanding liquidity in a way that causes
them to spend less they got to monetize
the assets that they have in order to
have that money to spend that's when you
start to get in kind of deeper trouble
uh in the economy totally totally It's
really more a function of jobs and it's
hard to see there's a couple things you
know uh that on the jobs front you know
the job losing your job no matter how
much cash you have in the bank you're
probably going to spend a little bit
less unless you're you know some YOLO
Millennial who thinks they can travel
the world on you know whatever budget
they have uh the reality is especially
if you have a family you lose your job
you're going to spend less money uh so
that's one big the indicator that we're
watching but the reality is
it's kind of reflexive if everyone's
still able to spin and oh by the way we
got some ridiculously positive retail
sales data this morning that we can talk
about in a second if everyone continues
to spin in an economy that's two-thirds
to 70 percent consumer spending how do
you have enough bad stuff in the economy
happen for a bunch of people to lose
their jobs you know it's been very hard
for you know I run a business and you
run a business it's been very difficult
to attract and retain talent in this
business cycle the employment the
population ratio is still down 140 basis
points from its pre-covet high the labor
force participation rate is still down
140 basis points from its pre-copic high
so there's millions of people right
around just so I have two million people
who were formerly employed are no longer
in the United States labor force and so
the the probability that companies
respond this early in the sort of you
know kind of deterioration phase with
firings Etc and in mass is actually
quite low in our opinion
Bitcoin what what are the thoughts there
this is an asset that uh it was balling
sixty nine thousand dollars in November
everyone thought they were rich now uh
it's coming down quite a bit 75 or so uh
as we've had to remind people there are
single stocks that are down more than
that but Bitcoin is down 75 or so uh I
know you've got some thoughts between
Bitcoin net liquidity and the uh kind of
broader macro environment how are you
thinking about this
yeah great question so let me take a
step back and I know you'll appreciate
this and your views will appreciate this
I think the number one thing we've
learned about Bitcoin this week is how
freaking resilient it is like yeah like
like like think about this like in
Middle 2008 when Lehman Brothers was
going bankrupt and the world thought AIG
was about to go bankrupt which is really
the problem everyone thinks it's Lehman
going bankrupt it wasn't Lehman that
really caused the big problems it was
AIG and all their derivative exposure
because mayman exposed what you know
aig's derivative exposure was if AIG
would have went bankrupt there was there
was a legitimate palpable fear that the
economy and all the financial markets
will go into a permanent state of
depression and I was around for that
like you know I was you know I wasn't as
smart as I was now about all these
Market Cycles but you know I was paying
attention and the reality is that didn't
happen but the Rea you know the reason
it didn't happen is because we had the
FED come out and pull out a bazooka we
had tarp I mean I mean it was an
alphabet soup of oh my God we got to fix
this because if we don't the stock
market's dumb the bond Market's done the
economy's done
that's not happening to bitcoin there's
nothing at all at fault or wrong with
the protocols and again I'm not the
smartest guy on the math and the science
behind everything but what I do
understand is that we just saw the
second largest crypto Exchange in the
world go belly up you know I'm not going
to make any you know I don't want to get
sued so I'm not going to say anything
about why they went belly up but but you
know they went Belly Up and guess what
the asset you know I wouldn't say it
Shrugged it off it went down in price
but that no nothing at all happened to
the protocols if anything it should give
you a tremendous amount of confidence
that this asset is here to stay when
something that major happens to it you
know it's not like oh people thought
that in March of 2009 people thought the
stock market was going to zero no one
thinks Bitcoin is going to zero in the
content even with all the stuff hitting
the tape so I just wanted to throw that
out there if you had any thoughts on
that
I believe that Bitcoin is doing exactly
what it was designed to do and part of
uh I think what has the people so
excited is that
people love to have control and some
sense of being able to
peacefully protest to peacefully protect
themselves to uh to participate in this
thing
at the same time the mainstream media uh
large financial institutions a lot of
those things they don't understand how
to play the game right it's kind of like
if you take the world's best baseball
player and you're like Hey we're going
to take you and we're gonna have you
play cricket
now it's similar
but it's different and if you don't
understand the rules if you may not be
as good at it if you may not even know
what the actual plays and strategies are
like you're kind of fish out of water a
little bit and so I think that's kind of
what goes on is that there's a whole
bunch of people that get pushed further
and further out on the risk curve
because actually uh in this entire kind
of large ecosystem Bitcoin looks the
most different from the Legacy Financial
system but the further you get out on
the risk curve the more it looks like
the old system
because now all of a sudden what are you
talking about you're talking about oh we
create coins we create things at a thin
air we insiders get them right like all
these things there's leverage there's
centralized platforms like it becomes
this whole system they're like yeah you
recreated Wall Street by the way cool
fine whatever I got it there's a lot of
people on Wall Street that make a lot of
money that help people that do all this
stuff there's also a lot of people who
do some sketchy [ __ ] too and like you
know there's bad outcomes yeah so it's
like like I get it but but I do think
that bitcoin's resilience is very
different uh because if you think about
it wall Street's not resilient it's
backstopped by the most resilient
organization in the world which is the
federal government and so they happen to
constantly have fdici uh FDI FDIC
insurance they happen to come in with
bailouts like they're constantly just
saying like we got the safety net
Bitcoin doesn't have yeah honestly it's
pretty interesting no it's a big Bitcoin
doesn't have a safety net it doesn't
need a safe net because if it's not
going anywhere you
know in the world is particularly the
ones that are most closely tied to the
center of the sort of Current financial
structure with respect to the reserve
currency status you know the U.S dollar
the Yen the Euro the British pound they
they don't want an alternative to their
hegemony to being able to capitalize
themselves at low rates they don't want
to hedge you know to having every good
and service priced in their currency
across borders that's a that's those are
exorbitant privileges of which you know
the us enjoys more than anyone by orders
of magnitude so um clearly they don't
want that but just on your point um
going back to sort of you know how much
the Legacy uh how much the the sort of
you know I guess I don't even know what
they call it the alt corn or the the the
the D5 space started to resemble the
transfer space and and one thing that
you know Jim Bianco made a great comment
on this uh and a recent podcast Steve
basically said hey look the main
difference between the defying Trap by
right now is in all the technology it's
just the fact that the tradify has the
Federal Reserve that can bail them out
of all these mistakes uh 5 does it
currently does not happen and so going
back to your original comment on net
liquidity I threw you that chart slide
eight from our from our macro Scotty
report you know where we show uh the 42
macro net liquidity model which is uh
the Blue Line in this chart here so the
uh the blue end of the chart shows our
net liquidity model which is the fed's
balance sheet the total assets on the
FED balance sheet and then you subtract
the treasure general comp balance from
that and you also subtract the reverse
repo facility balance from that and that
gives you sort of an approximate uh kind
of net liquidity function
um with respect to how much uh sort of
liquidity the government in aggregate is
supplying to the private sector and to
the financial markets ultimately
um so the black line is the uh Bitcoin
in the in the chart and the red line is
s p a purple line or pink wine is
ethereum as you see the title of the
chart so let me just take a step back
and explain a couple things as relates
to the FTX blow up because I tweeted
this out I want to say maybe last
Tuesday or Wednesday when poop was
really hitting the fan which is
it wasn't Sam Baker's freeze you know
Brilliance it wasn't uh cz's brilliant
sound you know the the pronouncer's name
wrong so I'm gonna go there but uh
apologies to him uh Mr binance
um you know it wasn't the Brilliance
these are brilliant people don't get me
wrong I'm sure they're very brilliant
they're well connected et cetera et
cetera et cetera but one thing that is
missing from this discussion
is the fact that we saw the sharpest
expansion not only in speed but in terms
of size and magnitude of net liquidity
and the history of the time series
between you know like of 18-month
interval so from like February of 2020
kind of were uh troughed in late
February of 2020 toward peaked in
November of 2021 I.E there were a lot of
crypto digital assets peaked net
liquidity expanded by
3.4 trillion dollars it it just it's
like that's like all the QE of the years
past combined and multiplied by two
right like it's just like in such a
short period of time we created Geniuses
out of people who created paper you know
or not paper assets digital assets right
and then oh by the way all it took was a
mere one trillion reduction in that net
liquidity from that November 2021 High
to today
to basically destroy the entire kind of
you know token uh whatever you want to
call a tradfi industry
um you you know obviously uncovered a
lot of cockroaches and some misbehavior
into fairies Behavior at least alleged
uh misbehavior but again that
misbehavior is a function of people
think they're the smartest guys and gals
in the room when again net liquidity in
like an 18-month interval is like going
up as fast as it's gone up you know over
the last decade by like a factor of two
so in our opinion you know all this
stuff is it doesn't happen in a vacuum
there's a reason FTX blew up in 2022 and
not in 2021 and that's specifically
because the blue line on that chart uh
is decline uh by substantial degree
as we look forward what is your
expectation for stocks real estate
Commodities and Bitcoin what do you
think plays out let's call it over the
next quarter or so I think which people
are saying hey going into the holidays
and kind of coming out next year a lot
of the same down only sideways uh rocket
recovery coming out of covet all over
again what are you expecting
yeah so uh just based on some of the
guidance we've received from the the
Federal Reserve as it relates to its
balance sheet uh product uh sort of
Battleship program uh the guidance we've
received more I would argue more
importantly from the treasury with
respect to you know kind of the the
projected changes in the borrowing
schedule how much they're borrowing
where they're borrowing on the curve and
ultimately kind of the their targeted uh
interviewer cash balance it's very
likely we see a substantial reduction uh
in net liquidity uh between now and year
end now the one caveat is we saw a 189
billion dollar decline in the reverse
Google facility balance uh month to date
in November to date and I want to say
around 150 ish of that uh has really
occurred since we saw that October uh
CPI report on on November 10th I want to
say and so what's happening is that
investors are feeling incrementally
comfortable taking duration risks taking
credit risks taking all sorts of risks
in capital markets and they're pulling
that excess liquidity out of the
reversible facility balance and parking
get into other assets and take risks if
that continues then you're going to see
the decline the increase the likely
increase in the treasury Journal comp
balance uh get offset alongside the
likely decline in the federal reserve's
total assets on their balance sheet now
we don't think that's going to increase
because again going back to the early
part of the conversation we think
consumer spending and ultimately a lot
of coincident and lagging indicators not
the least of which is the labor market
are likely to remain resilient for some
time which means it's very unlikely we
see a significant deceleration in
inflation that would ultimately allow a
lot of what we've seen over the last
week or so from reverse people facility
balance to continue in fact it may
actually start to reverse so to answer
your question on risk assets very likely
that we start to sell off from here into
now into year in but then it's likely
that we start to improve in the first
half of next year and in fact a lot of
those Dynamics I highlighted from an at
liquidity perspective are likely to
improve in the first half of next year
and I think there's going to be a mass I
think there's going to be a window of
opportunity on the long side out of risk
assets and perhaps even bonds as well
because investors are kind of too
bearish on growth as relates to the
near-term Outlook I think this path
towards recession is likely to be longer
than the average investor realized which
sets us up for multiple strings of
Positive Growth surprises in the first
half of next year so again I don't know
that we need to put that trade on today
because again we got some downside ahead
of us in our opinion
forward what is the one thing that
you're waiting for or the one thing that
you want to see happen where you'd be
getting excited in kind of hey I want to
be an investor again in this market
because right now being in cash has been
a great strategy uh for the whole year
like when would you be like okay you
know now it's time to uh start getting
excited is it just the fed and that and
they're in control
I mean I I hate to reduce macro down to
that but I mean and so look macro the
most important things in macro and why
asset markets go up why they go down is
really just a function of how much money
does the government need from us and how
easy does the FED make it for us to give
it to them if the FED makes it very hard
for us to give a give them that money
and they need a lot of money then asset
prices risk assets go down a lot if the
government doesn't need any money from
us and the FED oh by the way is making
it even easier for the money that they
do need from us to to for us to give it
to them then asset prices go up because
there's more liquidity on our side of
the table in the private sector to
actually Chase and capitalize Financial
assets and so if you think about macro
through that kind of basic lens and
start to sort of you know understand
some of the Dynamics that might make the
government need or more money need less
money start to understand and forecast
some of the Dynamics that might make the
FED inclined to make that process easier
or harder that's where macro starts to
get difficult and you really need some
some you know kind of experience or bare
minimum some somebody on your team that
can really help you with that so um but
going back to your question
there you know if you understand that
that's what's really driving the bus
here then yeah you really kind of do
need to see a credible legitimate fed
pivot not not you know to get really
sustainably long Bitcoin really start to
you know kind of you know increase the
size of your dollar cost averaging and
accelerate the the pace of your dollar
cost averaging in a way that you know
allows you to really participate in some
material upside I mean that could be
quite a ways away just given our
recession forecast but again I do
believe there's going to be a window of
time in the first half of next year for
risk assets to really do well uh before
we get to recession before markets at
the price and that credit risk we've
been saying in our research at 42 macro
that there's always two phases to the
bear Market and the first phase is the
sort of tightening net liquidity phase
you know where it becomes really
difficult for us to hand over money to
the government so we got to sell some of
our assets and our portfolios to make
that process works
um there's also the second phase which
is the credit risk phase where when the
economy really starts to slow down and
kind of head into a recession investors
start to get very nervous about you know
kind of their forward cash flow
estimates and their ability to sort of
um their ability to Value companies and
value credits and that's when you start
to see some significant sell-off that
tends to be where the capitulation
happens uh most bear markets that
process is kind of you know linear and
they're close together phase one is you
know it's generally you know kind of
follow uh quickly by phase two that was
like 2007 to 2009.
um I don't know that this bear Market is
it's like to likely to see that you know
it could be more like kind of the 2000
to 2002 we call it 2003 episode where
you had multiple months if not quarters
where the market was doing kind of just
fine on a off of a local low because
again you know the economy wasn't really
doing what it needed to do to cause you
know a significant change in bet policy
so
um you know that it's our view that we
might have that investable window but as
it relates to kind of expecting you know
a significant recovery in Bitcoin you
know well beyond this previous highs uh
that could be you know if not you know a
year away if it could be multiple years
away
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about 42
macro
uh I appreciate you man so uh come check
us out 42 macro.com you know I like I
said uh I think if we've learned
anything in 2022 is the value of a
legitimate institutional macro risk
management process has never been more
valuable and I don't think you need I
don't think you need to be an
Institutional Investor to benefit from
our services in fact when price our
services specifically so that everyone
can take advantage of it because you
know as you you know my background uh
very much uh grew up on the outside
looking in uh to a lot of this um you
know a lot of what we're talking about
today as relates to making money in
financial markets and so I want to give
back uh the best I can you know in terms
of you know allocating my time my
resources to helping everybody and so
come check us out do a lot of great
research at 42 macro a lot of very
actionable research and then I think you
know still I understand that not
everyone who's paying attention and can
watch can afford it some people might be
early in their learning Journeys or
early in their Capital Journey so
definitely come check me out on Twitter
you put out a lot of decent content on
there as well for free so I'm at 42
macro uh deep down on that platform
amazing
ladies and gentlemen we're going to be
doing this a lot more often maybe once a
week every other week we'll let you know
but uh every other week always well
maybe we'll you know it depends on what
happens at the market maybe somebody
will do something stupid talk about it
again all right uh as always I
appreciate talking to you and we
definitely will keep doing this so
thanks so much and I hope everyone
enjoyed it talk soon
appreciate your brother always man thank
you